[Music]
in insta scam news
it's the scam oh I get those all the
time where that tells me I'm verified
and at this sign into my account and I'm
like wait you just become verified I'd
ask David one time yeah that's when it
was like hot though like specifically
everybody was getting in the whole
reason why I knew that was fake because
like a couple of prints on buddy it
verifies like if you get an email from
Instagram and it goes at gmail.com
regain fish how do some people that have
like a thousand followers get verified
it depends if they're sponsored by
someone or if they know people aren't
submitted by Zoe without a Y so I'm
sorry Zoe without a ye take the Y away
though the OIE ze it's like what not the
why he chose open where they have the e
with the two dots okay oh yeah that's
expensi oh it's a Z is Z oh [ __ ] this up
Zoe look what it says without the Y okay
I got in another level or something
actress Jo Mila
Jameela Jamil is calling calling out
celebrities for promoting detox teas
online who's Jamila Jamel
I don't know that's not even a real name
dude Jamel Jamil Chanel we got a little
wobbly so to scam FEMA TV show a good
place it's a good show no no I want you
to leave geez trash anyway she's on that
show does know she looks like a good
place I like her hair cumulative like a
tease yeah I like her suit that's a
[ __ ] power suit yeah she looks a power
color that whole thing looks like 70s
yeah it does but her hair makes her like
come back you like your style huh I love
her style you too yeah she plays this
character called Jaime on that
so anyway so she tweeted this out okay
it says give us the discount codes to
your nutritionists personal chefs
personal trainers airbrushes and Plastic
Surgeons your bloody liars Wow
and so she's calling out like Iggy
Azalea Khloe Kardashian well amber
what's her name Rose or no wait I forgot
your name Amber Rose is the bald chick
is that who that is yeah yeah Amber Rose
and then cardi B so she's calling o what
I should call him I don't claim that
understand sucks t works like they got
their body through that t that they're
promoting so they can get money from
people to sign up but it was realities
work well so that Jamila Jamila is she's
saying
so there's another tweet she said she's
like they got cardi B on the laxatives
nonces nonsense detox tea
god I hope all these celebrities all
[ __ ] their pants in public the way the
poor women who buy this nonsense upon
the recommendation do not that they
actually take this [ __ ] they just flog
it because they need more money but you
know like the reason why this one that I
understand where she's coming from but
literally that's every product out there
I feel like she's kind of just hating
yeah you're flaming somebody for that I
like a hundred percent in Greece she's
not the first person I said that I've
been leave made fun of that [ __ ] on my
Instagram too you know like everybody
has I think that how angry she is about
it's like that's every product dude
that's every [ __ ] every [ __ ]
nutrition diet product is like that yeah
and it's even for for men for men yo
yeah it's really hard to say because it
seems like like she's just taking it and
a complete definitely cuz unless there
are captions from cardi B or amber or I
lost all my wig yeah I lost 50 pounds
drinking tea
most of the captions are like oh my
waist is slimmer and there is truth to
that because that you have a detox tea
you fast for 18 hours you take a fat
[ __ ] your stomach does you feel less
bloated peeing so it really depends on
like what they're promising and but
she's taking it I think like because
most people don't promote it as this is
the actual way I lose weight and I'm not
and I'm with David I'm not really for
any of these things like if you really
want to lose weight you have to fix your
nutrition and be in a caloric deficit
but these things they do have
you need a deep blow to do a little like
club night with your homegirls that she
probably works under for hours yeah tell
me that you could buy the same tea like
at the at the grocery store but it's not
that detoxed it's just a different brand
yeah and it's way cheaper that's his
white label yeah yeah well Jim is just
like all this is just laxatives it's not
healthy for your body and so well no one
says is healthy yeah so she also said
that I was a teenager who starved
herself for years who spent all her
money on these miracle cures and
laxatives and tips from celebrities on
how to maintain a weight that was lower
than what my body wanted it to be I was
sick I had I have had digestion and my
I'm not going to stop coming after all
the people men and women who perpetuate
this gross culture of forcing women to
remain small and dull like in order to
be accepted by society [ __ ] try me
see that's her projecting her personal
issues awesome you see I'm safe so she
read into something a lot more than what
it is because of how she experienced it
at a young age so now she's taking a
personal issue and on that like I said
I'm not defending this [ __ ] 50 and
detox tea or what rush it is [ __ ]
it is [ __ ] I think she's directing
her like mission and her anger and
aggression all toward the wrong people
yeah she wants to really make a
difference she needs to go to like FCC
or the advertising like people who make
up laws for advertising and all that
stuff and and regulate how this [ __ ] is
pushed out into the public or even
promote things that do work like find a
nutritionist or online coach that you
really like and promote them and be like
hey instead of trying to lose weight
through teas get under this guy's
program or whatever or change your diet
and it's like there's positive ways of
doing things like she did she did say
this too if you want to curb your
appetite eat some damn green vegetables
we got some nutritious natural vegetable
soup don't drink these detox teas you
need fiber not something that honestly
just makes you have diarrhea the day you
take it and constipate you in the long
run generally just don't ever take diet
advice from women who know nothing about
nutrition / basic advertising ethics if
you want to get healthier talk to a
trainer / doctor yeah she just said it
what you said that's the
for statement but I think all the hate
towards society society wants women to
be small like all that stuff it's her
like inner insecurity people have so
much influence over other people against
it she was influenced herself when she
was a kid she just she's pressuring them
to do better and because there's their
motor like a role model but sometimes
they don't even know you know it's like
it's like yeah like some chick that's
like oh you know what I put baby oil in
my ear and I should feel so good and
then she and her hair stylist might come
out don't [ __ ] listen to that [ __ ]
[ __ ] Society wants your hair to be
all shiny and [ __ ] for her you know it's
like why yet cuz I actually agree with
her yeah I just don't agree with how
she's going by doing it because it just
makes people close up their ears and go
you crazy [ __ ] yeah because if you
really want people to listen and if you
want people want people to learn that's
not really the best way to go by doing
this
yeah because how I see it is this is
right it's like something like this like
we don't like the way agriculture is
done right because of the way they use
water and how wasteful is right yeah how
she's coming at it now it's like I'm
eating this tenth ratios [ __ ] cutie
eating at [ __ ] I'm like whoa
and that's what is coming on that's what
it is like angry well you don't care we
really don't care about this date I
agree with all of you guys bought the
viewpoints and and I'm like okay yes
there's she's definitely going about it
the wrong way however we're talking
about it now so yes it was that in a
negative way but we would have never
known about it or her message even Cathy
we're not even talking about her message
we're just talking about how irritating
it is to hear yeah absolutely
like I said I agree a hundred percent
with that but if whatever she's trying
to do is working because she's getting
the attention of the people and yes like
Joe is saying it is gonna fall on deaf
ears because they're gonna be like damn
this crazy [ __ ] but she also had an
influence just as big and policy in the
way that that method is because that's
also saying saying anything is better
than saying nothing I don't agree with
that each year what I'm saying and also
like what I don't like is like so
obviously I'm in the fitness community
right and you don't see me like
in videos I'm taking the shake weight
and [ __ ] flipping it I like I just go
hey you want to get strong squat a
little bit yeah do a little bit
deadlifts like there's that approach but
I don't drag I don't drag people down I
don't go oh you see [ __ ] buff guys
six pack thirty-five yeah the shape
[ __ ] up how do you feel about this
thing all the guys are using a whole
bunch of steroids right yeah and they're
like here drink this
this creatine is what's gonna make your
muscles look whatever this whatever's
gonna make you like how does that feel
for me you're getting all of these all
for me I'm probably just as personally
angered about that misleading
information just as she is yeah but I
still don't come out flaming people
because for every single theme there's a
specific use for it
yeah there is a time and place for
steroids there's a time and place for
detox see there's a time and place for
it all of those things so when you come
out a big blanket statement like all
Society wants all guys to be it's like
that's when you kind of miss you're
skewing reality and then and now you're
dragging other people down and I'm not
yeah cuz that's where I was talking
about where she's bringing in her
personal thoughts and her personal
self-image issues and and putting that
on to other ppl so site she's almost
making it sound like every girl feels
like they have to be like that and
that's not true right you know what I
mean and like you're using cardi B for
example that [ __ ] is thick yeah she's
not a twig she might have been
constipated for a week as you need to
lose I will never [ __ ] my pants cuz
there's public bathrooms everywhere oh
and bushes so that was a response to
jameelah saying all that stuff and then
jameelah tweeted regarding her response
she will never [ __ ] her pants not
because of bushes but because she
probably doesn't ever take the products
she promotes sometimes it's cool so it's
a person it's these are personal attacks
yeah oh yeah and then lastly she she's
just finding easy scapegoats
these are personal attacks because she's
part like like you said she's personally
projecting all the [ __ ] that she
went through and she's blaming these
celebrities for her own [ __ ] that
she had to go through and then she's
acting like it's for the people and to
change their perception for about
nutrition and everything but it's really
about her trying to attack these people
and feeling good about herself exactly
that's what that's what it feels like
through the earth she posted this video
hi guys I just have to tell you about
this new amazing supermodel Shane I've
been drinking three days last night but
see they don't even say that on their
post so once again she's also she's like
projecting [ __ ] you know if she didn't
have all that angry messaging before
this is would have been a great video
yeah if she would have just did the
video without the whole [ __ ] spiel of
everything you that kind of like it this
is charming it's funny funny you're
right I agree she's just you know you're
right if she didn't say anything just
like that then people would be like oh
that's no it's not a satire you don't
mean that that comes across even more
effective that be more effectively a
long time ago - she also posted on
history grams a photo of herself and
like the caption over the photos that
something like anything could be a dildo
if you're brave enough and so she was
making fun of the people who put these
inspirational quotes over their video or
their photos so she does things like
that I like her but then when she does
the angry like tweets or whatever
instead of yeah said of her and calling
people out instead of her being above it
and joking about it it's actually okay
this she really got to her and then you
could feel her insecurities and then
kind of like lessens nother don't you
she did I think it boils down to this
how would I feel like from what I read
something that it's not
it sounds self-serving yes yeah I mean
yes so it doesn't sound like she's doing
it for a cause it sounds like she's
doing it for herself yes and that's what
makes me feel weird yeah you know like
her self gratification yeah like what
you're saying something ticked her off
which is yeah younger and it's a
personal thing she's projected she was
giving nutritional who was she she just
said you're not [ __ ] nutritive who
are you now yeah she's pretty much said
don't listen to cardi B but you have the
same knowledge as cardi B or you have a
PhD at the end of your last name you
know it's like that's like if I started
calling out all these guys that are
taking steroids and I'm like guys if you
really want to get fit just go [ __ ]
get a trainer so awareness that's
basically the same thing and I don't
think she's doing any great service to
society that hasn't been done
before I think a lot of people already
yes just said eat vegetables yeah she's
not doing anything that's like very
different and in like oh my god she's
Rosa Parks you know like say yeah like
what are we praising this girl yeah it
really does come from a very
self-serving place and I read through
all that [ __ ] if she stuck to just
creating content and satire I think
people are smart enough to get it they
watch and they're like yeah that is
pretty ridiculous
I know who she's talking exactly it's
like okay it looks like when I did this
[ __ ] like nude Instagram pics okay so
if I did that [ __ ] right amazing you're
welcome and you know if I did that and
then I wrote this whole like diatribe
about how terrible these women are and
I'm calling out these everyone's are
pissed
I know exactly you're making fun of the
minute I've already done you know and it
just makes you look like a really bitter
hater like a mean poor yeah you know
yeah
[Music]